Parents visiting their child's school
are frequently greeted with a raft of
impressive-sounding but impenetrable
education jargon.
One result: even informed parents
can walk away frustrated
and unsure if their child is in good hands.
So, here are five questions to ask – before the first day of school this year – that can help cut through the noise.
One: what's the best thing my child
is going to read this year?
Two: what one or two values are at
the heart of our school's culture,
and how will they be applied?
Three: in the typical month, how many hours
will be devoted to tests and test preparation?
Four: what's the one paper or project that I should
expect my child to come home excited about?
Five: what's the most important thing that
you think I can do to help my child
be academically successful this year? These questions are hard to spin and resistant to jargon.
And, no matter the answer, you'll walk
away with real insight into the year ahead.
What do you think makes for a good
classroom? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.